hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar evolution and utility of
molecular tests in the screening and
detection of HPV human
papillomavirus in Latin America I am Dr. Jose
Santiago Director of Scientific Affairs
for the Americas and I will be the
moderator for the event  today's
educational webinar today is
presented by the aplu and brought to you
by the molecular love science affairs group
for more
information visit the customer website
let's get started
but before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we invite you to participate by
sending as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply
write them in the 'ask performance'
box and click send or send we will
answer as many questions as
we have time at the end of the
presentation
if you have  problems viewing or listening to
the presentation click on the tab
indicated as  soporte or soporte that
is in the upper right part
of the presentation window we can
know about your problem by clicking on the
box make them work or ask
which is located in the far
left of the screen
now I introduce our presenter
today  doctor luis jairo bonilla osma the
doctor is a specialist in
gynecology and obstetrics,
the president of the
colombian association of colposcopy and pathology
of the lower genital tract and
medical coordinator of the
cervical pathology and colposcopy unit
saludcoop group is also a professor
of colposcopy and pathology diploma  del
teje y hospital de san jose and
scientific director of cuerpo latina s/a
for a complete biography of
our presenter visit the tab
go to radio biography at the
top of the screen doctor bonilla you
can proceed to start your
presentation welcome
thank you very much thank you
welcome everyone thank you very much for
giving me  the opportunity to address
you in the handling of the
important and fundamental issue for our
countries mentioned above,
the problem of cervical cancer
is a common problem for
all of Latin America,
why is
this problem similar in terms
of incidence and mortality in
all countries and that is the importance of
dealing with this issue
perez mexico and later in any other
latin american country to have the
opportunity to be invited before
beginning that there is simply the
slide where our conflicts of
interest
really as president of the
colombian association of contos  coast and
origin
to be able to integrate to participate with
different medical groups in the
implementation of these
screening strategies I have no conflict with each other with
the laboratory of with any other type
of pharmaceutical industry for all
that you can see here on the
slide
we speak specifically in coia  money
positivity demon se  The
incidence in Mexico is growing, it is close to 33
per 100,000, which means, and
we see it in the different shades
of color on the slide, that Mexico,
as I said, as well as many Latin American countries,
have a higher incidence
than countries like Canada, the United States, and
Like Australia, where the
well-dressed programs have managed to generate an
impact, the
incidence of mortality that
accompanies us late, is 50 percent, five
points, four per thousand inhabitants, and if
we do not carry out these figures,
we find that the anti-
immigration changes in the last  10 or 14 years,
this means that cervical
cancer continues in the medical field among the
first three constant causes of death,
and especially in
women, it is the second leading cause of
mortality
from a
numerical, statistical, and logical point of view, it is not
so  as shocking as when we
say good, but what does it mean
that four thousand women are dying at the same time?
year, what is the social impact of this
electric model and the
economic impact that it brings, sometimes each household
has two or five children and that
approximately 40 percent of the households have
women as parents to play with,
we are talking about a significant number,
almost  of eight thousand deaths a year
, among which in many countries,
the majority is important, not the majority, but
if not very important, as they follow this
example, my 300 children are going to be
completely abandoned.
of
these women feel that they are heads
of age by the only people who are
absolutely preventable
, which affects doctors and
especially those of us who direct scientific societies
who want to support
countries so that these figures decrease
both those of the attempt and those of
Mondragón mortality in the future as
we see elect slide also of the
panas you see that the sale in the
experience  from the drive because
by 2020 we are going to have a 5.4 percent
increase in the incidence by 2035
almost 20 percent more in the incidence of
cancer after the first and this
trend is obviously maintained in
mortality and we expect 6.4 percent  of
mortality for 2020 and we expect
23 24% more mortality for 2025 I did not
want to get into 32 40 these
are very long calculations so
when one sees this bad panorama of the
present and with a tendency to be worse
and one has to do something with  the woman
for the women
and that someone has her means and
work together with the doctor of wines and
the doctor of the Mexican college of the
body is conquered with them we work
in contact indicated that it is the concept of
the colposcopy clinic
removes from colposcopy that they are  the
management center of the articulated
chicken cancer prevention program
experiences because not only
vaccination is not only HPV testing, it
is the entirety of the program  it is to
guarantee the vaccination of the bibles
parts of their sexual life the practice of the
room with the healthy sexual culture
by the children
tettamanti parental for a single
opportunity in women clues from
which they will arrive at our health centers
for different reasons part of real  and
part of psychology written in this
way population from the point of view
of active search for those women
who do not want to participate in two
programs to extend control over
diagnostic confirmation and through
body copies in life
and is to guarantee treatment and
follow-up  to women, conditions,
prizes, rates,
an articulated program is the only thing that
guarantees us
Latin Americans control of this
fearsome truth
and this is why they don't make 23 because we are
going to do it
as we are going to do it
the juice that the 20 liter required I feel
the  swamp test
with which we are going to work since we have
the technology today gives us other
opportunities and how we are going to do it if
we have truly
organized programs in our countries
let's start by talking about it because it will be
very interesting to have a test that
helps us in the program
hopefully there will be a test that gives us as much
gp3 in the same test for me no costs
to facilitate in the
package industry and not have to resort
to a screening test, well, a
stretch mark test
after giving the patient
diagnostic confirmation during with your
own institutions, I hope everything
could be integrated, she
started dancing after the event,
how are they  the characteristics for a
pampa test
and logically it must be an
economical test that is comfortable for the
patient to take simple reproducible but something
very important to automate that they
leave us the additional
characteristic information is in the same test and
that it has an auto
and one of the pp for  follow up on
those very specific characteristics,
so the screening test  of
the human papilloma virus
with all these characteristics,
economic means that require the cost of the
test compared to the cost of the technology,
but rather the cost of the
5-year test-based prevention program,
then the doctor papanicolao could not continue doing the
same for
nine years in
finish three cancers through
psychology with the results wait for
this I showed you at the beginning of
this presentation or we can also
use these modern concepts that the
literature has confirmed to us that they are the
devil's workhorse in a woman
at risk we do not let her reach the
portent  we detected it before the
disease therefore it is not there and that but
what did doctor zur hausen teach when
in that clinical study that justified
the award today deméntieva found that the
main risk factor for everything
is the papilloma virus and that today
we have  tests
soon after taken by the
nurse by a doctor by the
bassist herself and bassist  amos for the detection of
the papilloma virus and why it is
important
after years of death mythology
we try the test of the
human papilloma virus as an instrument
of cancer prevention programs for
such second equation because the
typologies of year give us more
if  you see these dresses made
in costa rica peru in morelos the doctor
from which the sensitivity the victory
of 59 percent the color of it without
studies that we allow with a 52
percent sensitivity the typology is
the best excellent condition they take
excellent reading control  quality
medical pathologist and with the excellent
television conditions we cannot
exceed 50 60 percent of
happiness
and what is greater in the controls
explains that making the technology that
is taken every day is effective does not
reach 30 percent 35  percent that is
why we unite in this sense the
days in the theme of 11 13 because each
mistake is taken with the mind  has 30
percent chance of knowing
for gandin action
killed two instances that have
psychology this the dependent operator
the result is not automated from the
controls of pathologists and trails
the study of athens in comparison
between what exists behind this
attend the  Correlation of
Aragonese strabismus is a very interesting picture
that you see here for the diagnosis
of more than three points,
but if I am going to analyze the
sensitivity of the mythological laboratory,
then I will find that the
number one laboratory that reports me is the one with the
least sensitivity.  It has years for her
high-grade collections from this
point of view of these vicissitudes do not
occur with the HPV test in this of
the tests of this h
the four large laboratories in the USA
where experts have this clinical study that
I published circular deal with it 88 90
percent of tendilla although there is a
coordination and happy
and here we come from making point it will be then
nces mythology alice the
selection to the thriller no we cannot
deny that a liquid cytology to
reading
extremes technology
the series of cellular triptychs very few
as it touches too but psychology
before already offers to those of
us who are interested what is sensitivity  In
the detection of high-grade extraction, it
offers us the same as conventional technology.
The material of the collectors decreases.
The sensitivity for a high degree continues to
be the same as the
traditional typology.  I have given,
we have not been able to achieve anything that
we already have
when you are the speaker of the HPV tests,
you know in which groups of parents we are going to
use it, it is essential because
the three central ones must be used, for this
we have to resort to the prevalence of
s to
below
of positive ph and even more so if we see in the
plenary of the 18th of this year there are many
patients with behind and sectors with bt h
but q  That you are not going to develop an attempt
within this exercise so that
you can buy where I want you alone
if we take some
countries where the incidence of cancer is
low and we compare it with countries where
the incidence of cancer is high, it
is simply the exercise taken from
or randomly with some countries if
you find that the average
cancer for these women over 30
years of age
is much higher than to access here
we can see that they are under 25 years of age
where the art really is the
experience they are headquarters just
over 75  possible
and if we are going to talk about mortality
we find exactly the same and
we pass an average within these
countries in terms of
search mortality mortality in the age group
Tuesday at 30 years
much higher than the mortality presented in
age groups for more than 25 years where
is tactically
the power is what he means that while
it is true that most
girls are infected  s do not develop
cervical cancer with under
25 years of age watching the
cancer prevention program manufacturing checks for sh
must be positive from 25 to 30 2 here
we see happy others in different
color lines the different from
clinical studies as shown to
us  For example, the green
and party lines,
other studies, such as you can see,
yellow or blue lines, tell us
how the persistence of the virus does not
exceed 12 4 months,
thanks to this high viral treatment
in this very young population, we can
ignore them.  As for
so many people with human papillomavirus tests
in general, the flower of human papillomavirus
that is growing 35% more
diagnosis of my two hands and that is
a very big gain for this type
of population, that is why the
organization  panamericana de la salud the
world public health organization
in this manual for the start
of health programs where it tells us
we must from where you want and why
we must change because the literature
showed us that the
visual inscription mtb tests attended here are
useful to reduce mortality from
cancer and content
because they are products that can be
automated that can be taken by the
same woman who  ideologies have open
incivility it is true that
their implementation is going to face the
cost as soon as different from the paper
but in the end the cost of the strategy
is by perspective and what is more
important we are going to decrease
the incidence of cancer mortality
after a happy  then in this
value for manager tells us then
we had the vaccination we do not demand
education
in responsible sexuality but
we speak prediction of pledges or
verifiable and of the human language or with
visual inspection with acetic acid in
places, countries or areas of deadlines
resources and we must not forget  that
we should always have an
economic and competitive strategy at hand  It goes
to tertiary prevention for those
cases behind the French that have
escaped the processing program,
so
how productive are we going to see
the collar?
a lot of tests in this publication that you see,
doctor pollán describes
300 different tests for hpv but look at
only 120 and 130
approximately 37 percent
leonel trucco analytical evaluation the
chemical that allows the others until
we present ourselves study and also
treated so that  the implementation of
our country in the panic programs
actions and how to choose consciously in
all of silence to
choose to make the scientific the
property in that country of the choice that I
am not going to summarize in three practices what to
avoid this extra penal cent
as payment of  capture of glasses in the
first I believe that there was available in the
world to pronounce of cervical cancer
o uterine during the
qualitative description of Tetouan
therefore capture of Indians
used as the gold standard
more and more and a new test for its
validation
all these four studies indicated
what they tell us is that if the
test that we want to use
has at least 90% sensitivity
capture india 70 samples
altitude conditions or at least 98 percent
specificity of which our
video capture in 800 meters by
austin elections or neither one and that's why we three
and an inter correlation  Laboratory
with 87 percent confidence in a
minimum of one hundred samples is a
sample meets the criteria to
be used in the
cancer prevention strategy with design
here where I bring you the comparison,
let's say within the test,
the panel is also  one moment
cova depositories waste big time out
little described the
rapid tests since yesterday
as a blessing as the relative flexibility is  due
part for the diagnosis in my 22 for
the diagnosis of 1,003 that is
fully complied with the
physical reaction that I have just shown since they
are practically the same due to
superior line capture
and we can compare the different
scenarios
let's look at how the  tests
in valence percent a 3
percent prevalence of the ether to the customer
one and a half percent prevalence
you must purchase with any of
you sales the entity
is much higher than the sensitivity
of mythology for the fact that you are
telling the  97 98 percent
and it also has a specificity almost
similar to the specificity of the oil
the days since the HPV tests give them a
higher sensitivity and slightly
greater specificity more intensity
for blackmail in a healthy population and if we
see few publications where they will have
seven tests  of the escrache in terms of
sensitivity and specificity for its
performance of the patient with psic  ology
transformer that you are going to see the
same sensitivity is quite high
96 37 percent and the sin of all
the tests from the same which is
because each a very low positive predictive value
this means that the tests of
misfortunes detect women and  spy
but the beautiful triquis women don't affect him
so the
human papilloma virus tests for such a low value of the
device require a
second swearing
within the infected to choose which ones
are sick so that they go with
posco
and which is the treasure of the
human papillomavirus tests the high
negative predictive value
that is one hundred percent and
means that if the patient has the
peace test it is negative and the country's ecosystem
I have to see this patient again
and place no economic and
human resources  for five years with the
assurance that at the end of the plans we will
obtain a municipal profile
in terms of the life of the analytical  I
want to give you some incidental words,
but this topic seems very important to me
because frequently
we psychologists of experts in the system,
colleagues, tell us that one test is better
than the other that they have
heard has happened to them that
the test of  distance and he is not
weak to me but when they tell him round
clarity and metal I he directs then
the doubt is better that now it is
known to all three because there are
many factors at the laboratory level
a spark will be needed the most
important thing done this minute  of a copy of
hpv that has the patience, there are people
so that with the water test we have
100 percent positivity all
patients with hpv 16
need at least 500 copies of the iris
and what we give to use the color we would
need 1,500 copies must be
high  and 16 feet against the pi 253 of
this pair differences that have been maintained
for 18 bch 51 so depending
on each test
the numbers of  copies with different
side pieces were going to remove león
asks so it is better for example
active that kept 49 copies of positive mark
or it is bad cobas because it needs in 1,500
copies what would be the answer and the
answer to clinical sensitivity would
not allow analytical if I
have  a test that detects me
positive with a single copy of
detention where it works that I would have many
positive women from the palace of
inmates who would send health services
on the contrary and I have a test
a very high viral load is needed the
positive one
I'm not afraid if  I have let's mix the
concepts of asking for
clinical sensitivity analysis in the use
of a reading test. Let's
take these details into account the
presence of different pathogens
from the others in other signs than the
test of this that are not those of Asia and
family of complicity with  what is real
and that is true is having but that
also depends on your concentration
if we have c  On concentrations, for example,
from changing above 10 to 7
efe
we ​​are going to have an extraction of the
force of the pathogens that prevent it, but
depending on their concentration, the same
happens with some compounds 5 such as
inventive antibiotics, some
antifungals such as clottey plus sun
the plane the bleeding  of the sel is the
presence of blood or semen in the vagina
it can give us a test depending on
the concentration you have and
descending from the corpse it will need
to be more than 10% with estimation to
stop the tenth test it will need
more than 0 5% to  that treats the test of
these delicate tests different
behaves differently
these factors lack we do not take
into account when we take care
of good human tests in the
description of human papilloma virus
what else do we need to test sh that has
an internal control like a stream when
the  test actively to find out if
it was suddenly in the workshop tube
there was no sample no  s arrive between the
victory for that I need tests that
this count change lives and if the
bovine truth is negative and to be fallen and
shows that they can be represented
representative for a diagnosis of
an adequate analysis 3
not all the tests have
internal control not all the tests  they have
internal health control and there are no
tests where simply the environment and
there are no shots but not if there are
biological studies to analyze but we
must also take into account what
we talked about at the beginning of the talk
also has to do with the coronation  of
the hour cops
look at you that the correlation of the
rest of the biggest tests that are on
the market have a capacity when one
is definitely unlike
psychology which always mph from the bar the
placenta the laboratory that we need
to 'show
program of four
for  understand you for the detection of
how your moment is
but it is also different
and I will be productive and in your
specificity and we have to
manufacture it where we
initially manufacture it, this probable high
sensitivity is that they follow a
manufacturing strategy also for
many things high
sensitivity tests and there we have the
necessary tests
once we avoid those
positive patients we have the problem remember
you  that the sensitivity of the
pathology is more or less 30
percent and that we detect in the best
of cases 70 percent of the
patients of patients but when
we analyze the psychological normality
from 4 to 8 percent
but if we take into account  account the prevalence
of prices is 14% we are going to have three
times more positive ph levels of
abnormal smears and people tell me
added to the predictive value consisted
so low of the tests and a second
test the test that does not have
specificities on the day in  that we can
find the disease is
almost all airs would have
something paradoxical dig  Even for you, because
Egyptology has the sensitivity that
I just mentioned so low, Esther
lengthens her age, that is what she did,
now the couple exists, but they are
two blocks away from their bicycle, that is a
great paradox that forces
those processing programs, let's
focus on  We improve against the
clarity of mythology, this cannot be
reached among those whose strategy
would be to
make the expression in 67 this chemistry as a second,
but that would make
determination terribly more expensive
and then what would be ideal would be this topic,
I think that apart from giving 'life'
The search for the infected population
helps us comment on the accidents and those
who have the highest risk of disease
to send these patients at the
costs of the stress tests that have been
requested by this notification are at
this time and in the future the
most important tests for the
prevention programs because they offer us for my
family he not only shows and will support
the five patients  s in the trap
I am not saying this because a very nice study has been published by
doctor coss from
determining 10 different strategies for
baking lowered in genotyping
and by what specification confirm
that those people who have
1618 have between 7 and 16 percent more
risk of having latent disease
which should be immediate post copy
compared to 2 such as 43 and 53 which
are details that have extinct legal risks
with a hundred and in quotes
when we enter stress would not
justify that the bidder since the
type of virus in  So much so that it has a
risk of 4.3 percent and so
I would say slight
, the American guide to get out of this
5% limit will be directly at 0% and it
would be in patients with these types of
Pérez Bernal because I directly do
not want to confuse them because it would not be
necessary positive as the type of virus
that modifies the risk of having a
disease and 2.5 years open can
help me within a strategy  of
prevention of interior neck cancer,
let's look then at the study of the experts,
since they were tender, mentioning different
strategies within which he
only wants to emphasize this, where he
mentioned to do tests to see
what he does with gene typing and locate
negative patients to return
five years
against hpv 1618 daily
immediately after the post copies given
that they have a higher risk of
having to treat the disease
is a very good help for the
prevention program when the services for
diagnostic confirmation of body
copies if limited we would only send
colposcopy the 16-18 positives and the
positive patients with other types of
viruses we do pathologies to
decide if they are followed up or
tended to compounds
and now comes the program and turn off
finish but mention several things
about the programs depend on the
income level of  a time package in a country
with excellent resources but what  I want to give
less, you should start the combination with
medical tests already at 25 to do the
usual ones and the day together
only your own or the 16 positive visions or
the cytology are normal and
vital resources because the technique is not true
sensitive at 30 years  with dth to the
complements processing of the whole
life of the patients
the resources are less than 10 to 23 with
visual inspection technology and
send it to this position of algete in
patients with positive visual inspection positive
psychology 1618 positive and if
definitely the income in the
military only  You can use
visual restriction with only one
HPV test in a lifetime for women from
30 to 49 years old.
This is the interesting publication,
so the mind takes into account the
resource agreed with the previous publication. We
covered it, but apply the
stimulation model.  where
the natural history of the ph is studied and the bng
appears in this simulation as it already took
into account short pa  cient
ju women before starting their
sexual life when and list their life date the
probability of contagion with the virus
remember the prevalence of 14 to 23
percent many of these women in the
first two years after 70 90
percent several were clearly viral  and
10 percent of the women who
inhabited women who are not going to escape
the prevention program yet, as they have
advanced within the subject and will
reach the roadblock and this one to be
diagnosed with the symptoms
during the processing strategy  I already take
into account this
this scenario to which I
owe committing it between a
recruitment program then having you study it is
concluded for example
three officials have to contain up to date
I need the conflict to say
this to buy you has been imprisoned does not
complement your  past
eardrums and you after as there is
less evidence of hpv in the subject of five
years and I do not speak every three years the number
of body copies of the increase  in the
ascending 25 percent the cost of
screening will be less in strategies
every five years in strategies to make the
country
definitely the cost per year of life
per woman will decrease from 197 149 and
none of
the savings of the medical institution with
screening  of vph is close to 43
million dollars more or less 50
dollars per year of life to the opponent
let's look then what are the results
that we are waiting stand we enter into
a decantation strategy you
check letters the first is an
ostensible decrease in the number of
cytology  going from an average of 3
million psychology in the
stylized model of showing to 0
we should have a 35% increase in
abnormal psychology for a very simple reason
we have a prevalence of ph three times
greater than the psychological abnormality
we should expect 25%  more than
colposcopes but here comes the
favorable 44% more general diagnosis of
lesions of two or more we
decreased by 15%  more
cancer incidence and 16% cancer mortality
this is the gain in
changing the strategy
a doctor for example
the author ivonne the doctor italo
published this article where
we are we can
without dollars in a strategy this
year when  They make you patients from 20 to 80
years old or when you change to 30 or 80 years old it is
different and the cost is very favorable
when cost strategies are used
with cytology and tests in the desired conditions
so sadly sterilizing to
tell you
today we have a new tool
no more
today we have proof of this art
that the room and trial offers us
today we have vaccines today we
have a large number of texts to
edit
that our women happiness dying
of cervical cancer to avoid
so many children orchards to avoid so many
parts of the normal
in this function that we do not have an
organized program that we have it has
that of colposcopy with a
political will that helps us  Help them to sacrifice
functions that there is integration between the
first level where that
vitality / dlp h will be taken between second and
third levels where
copies of bodies will be made to God and to the
histology laboratory where that is what I
can tell you by treating 107
interview these days  who are waiting for
radiotherapy chemotherapy united all
the technology of politics the desire to
make these attempts we will decrease
and gravitate as they present themselves doctor
in quotes the word perform the
cancer after being me I thank you
very much for your attention
I hope I have identical to you in my
presentation
thank you very much  doctor bonilla for your
excellent presentation very informative
now we will start the questions
and answers part
if you have any questions you would
like to ask please make the time
just click on the
ask that question or ask box which is
located on the far left of the
screen we will answer as many
questions as we have  he time
let's start with our first
question which is doctor bonilla in your
experience what are the trends in
programs in latin america
compared to other programs such as in
europe or the us
but in general
what i have been able to learn from peru
to cut the opportunity for countries  and
there is more evidence to change this test
from the entity to the fact it cannot be discussed
but also in the segment with countries
that do not have organic programs
as long as they do not organize themselves they can
calculate the costs of the implementation
of the tests we cannot rent
ourselves necessary must have tests  and
more than 25 citizens three years ago 5
before having this moment I think
that the problem is in the lack of
programs that of paris with
organizational programs argentina for example they are
only working on processing
the costs of the program but yes the
trend is  they ask us is to start
with 1:00 p.m.
the how and when is what is
trapped by the f  discharge from the event program
excellent the next question to
observe it would be necessary to implement
additional tests to improve the
triage of patients who will be positive
for hpv 16 or 18
well we are being attacked by
latency of breathing
at the physical monitor level and part of the
job as president of  the association
of bodies copies colombia but i entered
multiple cities in many festivals
try to educate communicate the gift of the
test which of prints which of
care because the problem on the
previous positive side is that you
actually do a btt test here and
do as  Yes, all because of
economic ideologies, but if I, how to
use 7, I could use ammunition, it
could make the program terribly more expensive
and let's remember the
Latin American countries are extremely low
.  the men cited because it
serves us very well as  our levels
of maximum notes because they know the
test and sing but we must save
the test at the piano because of mythology or
the notification the themes and non-metallic it
seems that we have time for
one more question
to the classical questions is
there any difference or evidence that
favor the sample taken by the
patient or self-take to see if it is a
sample taken by a health professional
this question is very interesting because
I was telling you that one of the advantages
of the back half is that
the woman can take the  Own our
data in your office because we know
that women do not participate in the
processing program because they do not have time
to go to take the sample or because of
invasion of the privacy of the rental,
so many studies and large
meta-analyses show you a test to
be taken  by one's own mind
exactly the same as the test from behind
and takes under the border by means but
the requirements are removed  for which
the test by means of peter and that
ideally is taken by an instrument
that without a brush instead of pique
a sponge tampon is used or
washed instead of growing, capture
to indium is used for example that sensitivity
dropped by 10 percent  He expressed himself when
having the internship when we enter into the
strategy, among all of us,
thank you very much, Doctor Bonilla, you already
have some others such as the
final comment that you would like to share with the
audience
and make it an experience. Thank you all for
this time for listening to me,
that we need
as a doctor more than  as a specialist
also in the health program or
president of some of the americas as a
doctor from the depths of my soul
to our dogs for our
women we have the tools
today to prevent them from dying of cancer
we only need parapolitics
to be able to leave many  thank you very
much thank you again doctor bonilla
for your time today and your important
i  nresearch we would also like to
thank pencil and our
sponsor agua molecular for
subscribing to today's educational webcast
before we go i would like to
thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting questions the
questions we didn't have time for
today and the  Submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by the
presenter via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration. The cross will notify you
by email when the
webinar is available for
playback. We recommend that you
share this email with  your
colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
thank you very much and goodbye